bon à titre personnel je me fous
complètement de l'écologie ça ne
m'intéresse pas a carrément non non ça
ne m'intéresse pas donc j'ai entendu les
jeunes qui scella la planète moi je t'ai
aujourd'hui tu vas tu vas la subir moi
je vois d'abord mon intérêt et
ponctuellement celui de la planète donc
là ça ne m'intéresse pas et je vais même
acheté une climatisation elle m'a fait
penser que je n'avais pas acheté non
mais c'est super de diffuser ce genre de
discours à l'heure de grande écoute sur
une radio nationale
c'est top
[Musique]
d'abord je tiens à dire
j'ai pu parler avec la paix mais il fait
son choix en conscience et c'est
quelqu'un qui est là montrait d'ailleurs
et est très mûr construit sa carrière
son engagement avec beaucoup de sens des
responsabilités
je n'ai pas parlé à zinedine zidane j'ai
une immense admiration pour lui le
joueur l'entraîneur et on a très envie
d'avoir dans le championnat français
un sportif et un coach de ce talent qui
a su ramener
trois grandes coupes que nous convoitons
beaucoup pour nos clubs donc moi je
souhaite pour le rayonnement du
championnat français pour la france qui
reviennent qui viennent entraîner un
grand club français ce serait formidable
[Musique]
j'ai essayé mais je me suis dit que
c'était plus intéressant le challenge
était de française de chanter en anglais
en france que les gens pensent que je
suis américaine et après quand il
découvre que je suis française ils me
disent que je me prends pour une
américaine je trouve que ça donne plus
de toit et les gars faut que je joue
moins un truc absolument incroyable dans
le métro en corée du sud vous allez être
choqués et ses escaliers
[Musique]
c'est n'est fait
en corée du sud il aime bien faire ce
genre de trucs pour pousser justement
les gens à prendre les escaliers plutôt
que l'ascenseur ou l'escalator pour tout
simplement limité en fait les risques
d'obésité qu'est ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
alors j'ai une info sur les toilettes
qu'il faut absolument vous sachiez à
chacun de tirer la chasse des particules
sont projetées jusqu'à deux mètres de la
cuvette c'est pour ça que l'union des
temps 17 américains vous recommande de
placer une brosse à dents à deux mètres
minimum des toilettes est la mienne est
à
un mètre cinquante